was als ob dieser kommentar vor 46
jahren gepostet wurde
servus sg zum herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ich habe in letzter
zeit mediabox ein bisschen abwechslung
in den kanal reinzubringen
deswegen gibt es heute eine neue folge
von google gepressten aber das konzept
schon erklärt paul preston falls nicht
noch mal ganz kurz
also man hat hier eine gute sache dann
hier aber eine schlechte sache die mit
der guten sache kommt und da muss man
sich entscheiden
macht man das dann drückt man den button
oder machen uns nicht klickt man einen
ort hier oben ich wollte ich einfach nur
wissen lassen dass gerade so ungefähr
fühlt der größte shitstorm aller zeiten
auf youtube abgeht und die
amerikanischen youtuber der fein raus
100.000 der bus am tag was eigentlich
ziemlich geil ist ich hab euch das video
verlinkt schaut euch einfach mal das
like dislike verein ist anders ist zu
krank gutes war ich nur sagen ich wollte
jetzt keine eigene drum machen so
mangold youtuber 400.000 euro noch
kümmert aber wir wollen den button
pressen oder auch nicht
ich entwickle eine heilung für krebs
aber jeder krebspatient bruch eine
transfusion von meinem eigenen blut das
heißt es die ganze blutspenden muss um
krebspatienten zu heilen
ich würde es auch machen ganz ehrlich
ich würde es machen scheiß drauf dann
ist man zwar total dramatisch und hielt
vielleicht zwei wochen durchkommen ab
kratzt aber dann hat man halt 14 leute
das leben gerettet
lohnt sich weil sie ein leben gegen 14
eintauschen das ein guter deal machen
wir übrigens wisst ihr was ich richtig
cool wenn ihr euch selbst so szenarien
aus denken also kombinationen zum
beispiel du hast das schärfste schwert
aller zeiten in einem schlafzimmer aber
du schneidest sich jeden morgen so oder
so auch wenn ihr selbst ideen habt für
solche situationen die daraus bestehen
okay du hast richtig cooles aber dann
hast du keine einschränkung dann
schreibt die fr und in die kommentare
ich bin mal gespannt ob da was gutes bei
rumkommt dann mache ich vielleicht mal
so ein video das sich nur um eure
kommentare dreht also nur um eure
vorschläge und ideen das für eine mega
geil wieder was zusammen bekommen wer
cool und ihr könnt ein bisschen mit
daumen hoch daumen runter bewerten was
er cool findet vor den vorschlägen der
anderen also wie gesagt dass das
grundprinzip ist du hast ja was richtig
cool ist wie zb du kannst fliegen aber
um fliegen zu können musst du benzin
trinken oder sowas wie so was also eine
coole sache und eine einschränkung die
mit dieser coolen sache kommt wenn es
ideen habt ab damit in die kommentare
du hast einen wunsch frei kann es ja
alles wünschen was du willst aber du
kannst dir nicht mehr wünsche wünschen
ja ok scheiß drauf weiter
ich kann mir eine sache wünschen egal
was es ist und dass es keine wirkliche
einschränken als es nicht so ich kanns
ja eine sache wünschen aber dein bein
fällt ab oder so was ich kann einfach
nicht mehr wünsche wünschen da wird
wahrscheinlich eine dauer auf das glück
oder zufriedenheit wünschen oder wieso
was er ist gut
ja das auf jeden fall auf jeden fall
mache ich das okay ich werde als held
und legendärer schwertkämpfer erinnert
aber ich sterbe einen langsamen
schmerzhaften und heldenhaften tod von
enke wieder nicht des steht sondern
werte aber ganz ehrlich warum legendärer
schwertkämpfer werden wenn man auch
jetzt über sein kann mache ich nicht
mehr
dann stellte ich lieber einen nicht so
schmerzhaften nicht so langsam tot aber
halt nur youtube und nicht als als
legendärer schwertmeister youtuber ist
eigentlich auch so cool wie legendärer
schwertmeister oder auf jeden fall
nein 58 prozent hätten das gemacht hier
oben 58 prozent hätten sich dafür
entschieden legendäre schwert meister zu
werden und während dafür einen langsamen
schmerzhaften tod gestorben
alter schwede was ist mit den leuten los
als allererstes müssen wir erstmal hier
die sonnenbrille astrid bringen ganz
wichtig die habe ich die ganze zeit über
vergessen man leute das ist die
ultimative frage das ist die ultimative
frage du kannst alles materialisieren in
dem müsst ihr nur vorstellen
materialisieren heißt du kannst alles
entstehen lassen die müsst ihr eine
vorstellt das heißt bei dem jetzt
baustelle beim ein einhorn mit
kuhflecken der integrierten xbox one und
2 40 zoll monitoren also ja ich vorne
einhorn kuhflecken 2 40 zoll monitore so
bleibt davon installiert dass du wenn du
auf dem ein und reiter zeitzeugen kann
neben pc da haben einen pc mit zwei
monitoren oder guten verbindung soll es
live stream kann vom iphone heraus aber
aber man muss jeden einzelnen knopf auf
youtube resta button kommt drücken und
alles was jemals hier pourie posse
button steht wird meine neue realität
ich muss alles machen was ich irgendein
verrückter mensch da draußen jemals
ausdenken und diese seite postet da
kommen locker richtig kranke sachen noch
nie das dass es zu krass dass es zu
krass jetzt bin ich gespannt wird wie
das aussieht während während ich die
leute entschieden
2 50% es nicht gemacht weil sie die top
lösung hier hab ich einfach auch hierher
zu kommen was als ob dieser kommentar
vor 46 jahren gepostet wurde
ist vor 46 jahren niemals alles klar 6
40 jahre das internet gab es noch nicht
aber wohl presse.com existierte schon
und andy turm hat eine kommentar
gepostet wohlgemerkt dieser vorschlag da
oben existierte auch schon vor 8 46
jahren aber hatten 66 40 jahren nur 29
exempel
die leute mögen wirklich nicht okay das
ist noch mal eine richtig gute sache und
zwar bedarf nach hogwarts aber du musst
ins labyrinth sein
und wisst ihr was ich habe öfters
darüber nachgedacht in welches hogwarts
haus ich gehen würde wenn ich noch was
kommen würde und ganz ehrlich prüfen ist
vom mainstream dürfen uns vom mainstream
ich habe bock rief deshalb ist mason
griffin langweilig meine kleine
schwester griff nur in greven clown
havel passt in mega mega langweilig also
niemand will nach raven klaasen finde
ich ja nicht so schlimm ich würde
außerdem gehen auf jeden fall auf jeden
fall also nach hogwarts gehen und dafür
institute seien überhaupt kein ding 71%
aufgemacht auf mega spannend hier
du kannst alles haben was du willst wann
immer du haben willst aber du musst
jemanden dafür töten in der folgenden
minute
da muss ich sagen bockt klar wissen was
man nämlich machen kann man kann einfach
irgendwelche gaal in sachen machen
ihr könnt machen was ihr wollt und dann
bringt ihr einfach irgendein menschen um
der andere menschen umbringt und bösen
menschen oder irgend menschen dass der
sowieso auf die auf die todesstrafe
warten unschuldig ist all das ist der
perfekte plan als allererstes wünscht
man sich das vollkommene wissen über
alle verbrechen aller menschen auf der
welt und dann weiß man genau wer böses
gemacht hat wer schuldig ist wäre es
vielleicht verdient hat zum beispiel mit
diesem wunderschönen mordwerkzeug hier
damit um geliebt zu werden und dann legt
man einfach die bösen menschen um dann
weiß man für immer wer was böses gemacht
hat und dann kann man sich alles
wünschen weiß genau ob er ist böse
damals beispiel okay ich möchte
weltfrieden haben okay dafür steht jetzt
der da oder neues auto oder eine
bestimmte er aber wohlgemerkt nur böse
menschen wenn es nicht böse menschen
geht würde ich es machen ansonsten wenn
es mit konvention uhr gute menschen sind
dann nicht fair wäre so krass egoistisch
gute menschen dafür umzubringen und dass
er sein eigenes deine eigenen willen
bekommt wer wäre so pessimistisch events
sehen
ich würd's nicht machen 60 prozent
hätten es gemacht alter water voll witz
nein
60 prozent und es ist einfach schon
wieder ein kommentar davon vor 46 jahren
warum vor 46 jahren gab es kein fucking
interview was ist los
wenn ich jetzt einfach ein igel hier auf
einem stuhl um mich dann umdrehen und
dann bin ich weg
das ist ja super strange